bonjour guillaume lacroix merci beaucoup
je ne reprendrais d'être notre invité
politique ce matin vous êtes le
président du parti radical de gauche et
vous soutenez christiane taubira qui a
remporté la primaire populaire hier et
on va en parler avec vous pendant 20
minutes puisque nous sommes ensemble
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
favorise au cerveau dont bonjour
guillaume lacroix branche pour les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
et on va parler bien sûr avec vous cette
primaire populaire que christiane
taubira a donc remporté hier soir sans
grande surprise est-ce que ce matin elle
est autre chose qu'une candidate de plus
à gauche d'abord y sait pas c'est un
événement politique dans le pays quatre
cent mille personnes se sont exprimées à
gauche dans une gauche qu'on disait
atone eux qu'on disait finalement
incapable de se mobiliser incapable de
croire au fait qu'elle pouvait peser
dans cette élection présidentielle
quatre cent mille personnes ont décidé
de s'exprimer ils ont donné une majorité
nette à christiane desbiens ils ont
aussi voté en nuances puisque
contrairement à ce qui était annoncé
c'est pas le plébiscite bien c'est aussi
à yannick jadot qui obtient tout en
ayant tenu à distance le dispositif un
score très honorable il y à bien même
chose pour jean luc mélenchon donc c'est
un événement politique en soi un
événement politique qui va continuer de
faire de l'éco aujourd'hui puisque on
entend même si c'est pour la critiquer
tout le monde parlait de cette primaire
populaire dans tous les appareils
politiques même si c'est pour en dire le
plus grand mal certains on disait le
plus grand bien avant décide maintenant
dans dix ans le plus grand mal chaque
elle est une candidate qui continue son
chemin de rassemblement c'est la grande
différence aucun des candidats en lice
aujourd'hui n'était légitime tous disent
je suis candidat du parti socialiste
europe écologie verts avec une vraie
légitimité aucun ne dispose de
légitimité aussi large citoyenne que
celle qu'elle propose mais surtout elle
est la seule qui depuis le début dit moi
je veux qu'on sorte de l'impasse il dira
soir que chacune et chacun est légitime
à défendre sa famille politique mais que
ceux qui comptent le 10 avril c'est pas
un bulletin de vote taubira c'est un
bulletin de vote de la gauche qui mène à
l'elysée et c'est ça qu'elle va
continuer à se développer
guillaume et accroît le problème c'est
que personne ne veut s'effacer derrière
personne sauf que là n'est pas possible
de s'effacer à christiane taubira dans
le sens où christiane taubira
n'appartient à aucun parti christiane
taubira c'est pas le fait qu'on se range
derrière une étiquette préexistantes
n'est pas le candidat du prg depuis le
début je le dis
moi je dit depuis le début que ce que
nous soutenons et ce que mon parti m'a
demandé de soutenir c'est une
candidature de rassemblement de la
gauche tous viendra al'avantage d'être
libre au dessus des partis c'est
quelqu'un d'assez inclassable à gauche
c'est aussi sa force aujourd'hui où on
s'en faire dans les problèmes d'éthique
est qui parfois ne veut plus dire grand
chose taubira c'est une capacité à dire
à toute la gauche vous n'allez pas
devoir socialistes vont générer 1 les
verts vous n'avez pas écologiste devoir
vous ranger derrière les socialistes
vous allez pouvoir vous mettre côte à
côte dans une candidature qui finalement
n'appartient à aucune des familles
politiques parce que je l'impasse dans
laquelle et la gauche serait elle n'est
que celle là ian brossât le patron du
parti communiste lui dit la poésie c'est
bien en parlant de christiane taubira
qui renvoie qui donc faire dans une une
caricature de poésie
en filigrane ça veut dire elle a pas de
programme et qu'est ce que vous en dites
d'abord je trouve absolument
extraordinaire les mots aigres-doux de
toute la gauche en crescendo bien quand
on sait que depuis des années à chaque
meeting de chaque élection intermédiaire
chacun à rêver invités souhaité qu'au
tessin sociale et de le soutenir c'est
malgré tout une forme je trouve peu
respectueuse aujourd'hui de leur part de
lui rendre hommage de ce qu'ils ont dit
d'elle et hier la seconde chose c'est
que on peut enfermer taubira dans toutes
les caricatures en ce moment c'est le
jeu puis un mois je ne lis que des
caricatures surtout bien c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs parce qu'elles inquiètent les
caricatures c'est taubira est
anti-républicaine c'est les caricatures
taubira n'aime pas la laïcité taubira la
croix rousse quand elle déclare sa
candidature elle dit la république
indivisible laïque est notre bien le
plus cher nous le défendrons contre
toutes les attaques des plus sournoise
ou plus frontale moi je veux bien qu'on
m'explique qu'elle serait lâche sur ces
questions je me suis fier vous l'avez
entendu guillaume lacroix elle a parlé
d'une à une cité qui écrase non ce
qu'elle est ce que c'est des mots a dit
mon souhait c'est de trouver des
réponses pour une aide pour une laïcité
qui n'écrase pas mais qui n'ont cessé ce
cas la firme
mais c'est aujourd'hui nous savons que
les ennemis de la laïcité passent leurs
journées à expliquer que la laïcité
c'est l'ennemi et que ça écrase l aile
d'hier soir non ça n'écrase pas mais ça
y est mon cycle pardon la vieille maison
radical de gauche républicaine laïque
aux origines de cela depuis toujours
nous disons que la laïcité c'est la
valeur cardinale de l'émancipation je
mets au défi celles et ceux qu'ils
m'expliquent depuis hier soir que ce
serait une atteinte à la laïcité que de
venir dire que c'est la liberté
émancipatrice de tous les dogmes celle
qui fait que vous avez le droit de
croire ou de ne pas croire que vous avez
la capacité aussi de vous distancier des
croyances et bien c'est cela la laïcité
et moi je trouve qu'une candidate de
gauche qui affirme que non la laïcité
n'écrase pas mais quel est mon cycle est
totalement dans le droit fil de ce
qu'est la tradition républicaine de ce
pays et c'est là où je vous dis qu'il ya
des caricatures qui vient aussi
forcément des calculs politiques justes
pour finir sur la laïcité il ya aussi
des faits christiane taubira elle a voté
contre la loi de 2004 qui interdit le
voile à l'école est-ce que ça aussi
c'est celle et le prg avaient voté pour
cette loi 2004 crise un taux bien voté
contre quand il tente nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur ce point il y a quelques
mois une marche contre l'islamophobie
est diligentée dans paris en demandant
l'abolition de la loi de 2004 christiane
desbiens prend ses distances avec cette
marche publiquement sur aube où elle dit
qu'elle ne comprend pas la question
qu'elle ne comprend pas la réponse et
qu'elle n'est pas en accord et qu'elle
n'ira pas moi je pense que c'est une
démarche n il y avait deux parties deux
parties pour ne pas s'associer à cette
marche le parti socialiste le parti
radical de gauche donc on peut faire
toutes les caricatures mais je le redis
il y as derrière tout ça des calculs
politiques est-ce que christiane taubira
est une candidate avec un programme
aujourd'hui je reformule ma question de
tout à l'heure ce système qui parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on à la
candidate mais qu'on connaît pas le
programme jeu permet des caricatures on
va là encore une autre christiane
taubira trente ans de vie politique
n'aurait donc pas de pensée politique à
part celle de rené char
je viens le programme elle s'est
exprimée sur le pouvoir d'achat elle
propose clie une revalorisation des plus
bas salaires et donc du smic à 1400
euros elle propose qu'il n'y ait plus
personne de payer au dessous du smic
parce qu'il ya des personnes payés en
dessous du smic elle propose une
conférence salariale autour d'elle
autour de la présidente de la république
elle pourrait être pour faire évoluer
les salaires nous sommes quand même dans
une période d'inflation extraordinaire
dans énormément d'entreprises dans le
pays aujourd'hui les salariés se
mobilisent pour demander un retour à une
augmentation de salaire elle propose par
ailleurs de d'encadrer les prix
l'essence pour permettre de stopper
l'inflation sur ce produit qui est
nécessaire à beaucoup de nos concitoyens
pour aller ne serait-ce que de
travailler elle a un programme sur le
pouvoir d'achat quand elle dit sur la
santé cent mille fonctionnaires de santé
en plus quand elle dit qu'il y aura
nécessité d'avoir un point de santé à 30
minutes de chez soi vous reconnaissez
quand même cas les moins avancés dans
son programme que jean luc mélenchon que
yannick jadot qu'anne hidalgo fabien on
sait qu est ce que vous appelez un
programme parce que si un programme
c'est un catalogue de 110 mesure de 200
mesures que personne n'est pas ça un
programme moi j'appelle ça un catalogue
d'idées de propositions dont on ne sait
jamais laquelle l'on porte sur l'autre
dont on ne sait jamais ce qui est
prioritaire dont on ne sait jamais
finalement laquelle sera vraiment
appliquée moi j'veux qu'on peut se faire
tous les procès du monde à gauche enfin
à ce moment de notre histoire au moment
où dans ce pays la gauche est largué
hors jeu est ce qu'on a vraiment que ça
à faire que de s'envoyer à la figure à
longueur de journée le fait que untel ou
unetelle n'aurait pas de programme moi
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait une maison
politique aujourd'hui qu'ils n'impactent
pas ça veut pas dire qu'elle fait
campagne sur sa personne et que c'est
aussi
[Musique]
mi temps de la primaire populaire qu'ils
ont quand même choisi avant même
qu'elles disent qu'elle était candidate
et avant qu'elle dise qu'elle revenait
en politique pour cette élection est-ce
que c'est pas plus à personne que son
programme qui est qui et publicité
finalement et la lucarne je vous le
disais tout à l'heure cette capacité de
rassemblement la primaire populaire
c'est pas un vote d'un parti politique
on est tous d'accord là dessus mais
c'est bien plus que le nombre de nos
militants cumulés dans tous nos partis
politiques grâce à google est donc
aujourd'hui ce que dit cette primaire
populaire elle dit pas on s'est choisi
un chef de la gauche elle dit on s'est
choisi quelqu'un qui peut rassembler
parce que je le redis le sujet il est
uniquement là est ce que le 10 avril il
y à un bulletin taubira ou un bulletin
il alloue un bulletin jadot ou est-ce
que le 10 avril il y à un bulletin de la
gauche qui va à l'elysée c'est quand
même ça le fond sûr qu'il y aura un
bulletin taubira le 10 avril est-ce que
là elle est lancé jusqu'au 10 avril ou
est-ce que si elle ne réussit pas le
rassemblement et bien elle dira j'ai
échoué les conditions du rassemblement
qui
aura t il des signatures écoutez les
signatures d'abord les les élus de ce
pays sont libres ils n'appartiennent à
personne le berger a un vivier de
signataires qui se sont bien engagées
382 exactement donc alive mais je n'ai
pas jailli dans le taux de retour au prg
comme le taux de retour partout il ne
s'agit pas de dire par principe et puis
ma famille politique a ses faiblesses ou
cette force moi je trouve d'être une
famille politique de femmes et d'hommes
libres et donc personne n'est qu'à
paralysie a pas de signature automatique
ça n'existe pas sûr que j'entends hier
soir par contre 2 mai et lui c'est qu'il
trouve que le discours de christiane
taubira qui en appelle à toutes les
sensibilités de la gauche qui reconnaît
que toutes les sensibilités de la gauche
qui pour le coup ne joue pas contre le
ps contre les verts contre les
données sur la question des parrainages
faites le bien il y a le serment de
romainville qui sont ces femmes et ces
hommes qui s'était engagé à saisir pour
celle ou celui qui permettrait le
rassemblement ils sont 200 signataires
de mémoire il y à ses élus que les gîtes
alors c'est sûr ces serments de rendre
un bien effectivement ce sont des élus
de gauche qui ont dit non refuse pour le
moment de parrainer les candidats qui
sont des candidats de notre parti on va
farine et celui qui crée les conditions
du rassemblement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
christiane taubira écrit assez les
conditions du rassemblement pour avoir
les signatures de ces idées ont du
travail enfin je le dire soir tout
commence la question dire ça c'est pas
je le redis ça n'est pas une primaire
d'un parti ça n'est pas la décision
d'une formation politique de dire voilà
ma candidate c'est un appel de citoyens
qui disent nous voulons un rassemblement
il nous pensons que ce rassemblement il
est possible autour de christiane tout
bien cents ou bien elle l'a dit hier
qu'elle en appelait à toutes les
histoires politiques elle a dit hier que
maintenant cette femme âgée vous n'êtes
pas sûrs d'avoir les parrainages pour
vous connecter oui enfin dire quand même
je voulais 10 des réseaux d'élus qui
sont là et qui ne sont pas complètement
poète sur ces questions là donc
fondamentalement le problème n'est pas
là le problème il est heureux on ne peut
pas jouer une élection présidentielle
uniquement sur un jeu que je trouve
assez malsain et de dire moi j'ai mes
parrainages vous vous les aurez pas les
parrainages c'est le 4 mars à 18 heures
donc on verra le 4 mars à 18 heures qui
les a et qui ne les a pas
marie
christiane taubira n'étant pas une
extrémiste n'étant pas quelqu'un qui
clivent très fort élan chance un expert
non j'ai dit laissez-moi finir mme
affret madame le pen est une extrémiste
monsieur mélenchon cliff très fort
c'était la phrase que je venais de faire
au moment où vous m'avez coupe est
évident c'est pas christiane taubira je
vous confirme également c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
est embauchée sur le financement
tout comme pour tous les autres
candidats la même problématique pour
tout le monde selon ce que vous peser
dans les sondages selon vous avez des
six nations où vous n'avez pas les
questions se règle ou ne se règle pas là
dessus il a pas d'ambiguïté petite
question au président du parti vous êtes
vous évoqué hier un événement événement
national avec ce vote mouvement
politique événements politiques 400
mille votants
est-ce que ça n'est pas la fin et partis
politiques vous soutenez vous avez pas
porter votre soutien plein et entier à 7
à cette démarche et est-ce que ça n'est
pas la fin des partis politiques vous
savez je crois que le premier à avoir
fait une proposition de loi à
l'assemblée nationale pour que le
système de primes et à se généraliser en
france s'appelait roger gérard
schwartzenberg
il était du parti radical en 2011 quand
il vit à la prime aux premières grandes
primaires de la gauche jean michel
baylet candidat compte en 2016 ça se
renouvelle sylvia pinel est candidate et
je crois que nous avons fait l'analyse
nous depuis longtemps que notre
démocratie changé les partis politiques
sont essentiels pour structurer la vie
démocratique du pays et c'est un chef de
parti qui vous le dis donc je ne vais
pas vous dire le contraire mais il faut
aussi entendre que l'engagement militant
qui soient pleins et entiers dans la
durée pendant 30 ans en acceptant
finalement les difficultés dans
l'engagement militant est quelque chose
qui est en train de se modifier
aujourd'hui vous avez des citoyens qui
sont capables de se mobiliser on voyait
sur une thématique qui est l'union de la
gauche et ce sont 400 mille citoyens
actifs qui pouvait faire ça dans un
parti politique c'est jean luc mélenchon
il a basé sa candidature sur l'idée qu'
il était candidat son débat avec
personne et qu'il lui fallait 150000
clics sur internet non contrôlée par
personne ce qui l'a fait madame hidalgo
a été élu au sein du parti socialiste
légitimement son débat non plus et elle
a été élue avec un peu plus de quinze
mille voix monsieur jadot et passer par
une primaire écolo qui à elle permis de
réunir 100 mille votants ça c'est ce que
les partis politiques savent faire il y
a hier soir des citoyens qui se disent
nous aussi on sait faire on sait faire
autrement et le vrai sujet c est ce qu
on joue le jeu des parties contre les
citoyens moi ce qui m'inquiète et ce qui
pourraient maquer t sur la disparition
des partis politiques c'est si on disait
ce qui s'est passé hier ça n'intéresse
personne
comment vont-ils faire dans leur
programme pour expliquer qu'ils sont
pour la nouvelle démocratie pour le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
comment vont-ils faire pour être
crédible auprès des citoyens en disant
simplement quand c'est dans mon
programme c'est bien mais quand c'est
pas moi qui en ai décidé je n'en tiens
pas compte c'est sacré c'est bien parti
pour christiane taubira hier elle en
appelle aux électeurs de toutes deux
tout bord un socialiste écologiste
communiste elle en appelle d'abord aux
électeurs après elle en appelle aux
militants après elle en appelle aux élus
de terrain elle en appelle pas aux chefs
de partis ou alors longtemps après dans
son discours est ce qu elles mêmes elles
jouent pas le jeu de partis politiques
contre citoyens n'ont pu s'établir à
elle est respectueuse ce qu'a longtemps
vous avez des chefs de partis vous avez
des candidats qui disent nous ça ne nous
intéresse pas ça n'existe pas c'est une
machination c'est une mascarade vin
kouté c'est quand même la première fois
que j'entends autant de gens de gauche
essayer de gérer leur de faire passer un
vote citoyen pour quelque chose
d'indigné par no 1 mais c'est ça
m'interpelle quand même ce matin de ce
que j'entends de bonnes intentions chez
chacune et chacun depuis tant d'années
donc ce qu'elle dit simplement hier
c'est je vais quand même appelé anne je
vais appeler yannick je vais appeler
fabien je vais appeler jean luc du leb
allemand
elle a dit je vais acheter elle va à
celle là est donc et elle dit quand même
on respect par rapport aux candidats
dont elle redit la légitimité pour
chacun de guider leur famille politique
je pense que c'est quand même
extrêmement important s'est il n'y a pas
de volonté de passer par dessus mais à
l'entente ce qu'ils disent elle
s'adresse aussi à l'intelligence
collective de ceux qui militent ne sont
pas à leur dire allez
circulez ya rien à voir qu'est ce
qu'elle va leur dire écoutez les scènes
taubira des capacités de conviction que
personne n'ignore on voit d'ailleurs fin
d'un mois elle est passée de j'envisage
à être candidate et de sortir la gauche
de la passe à un vote de quatre cent
mille personnes qui pour près de 50 %
d'entre eux la place parmi la candidate
la mieux placée donc on voit bien que ça
ne tombe bien à des capacités de
conviction dans des temps record moi je
crois
enfin pas forcément les sondages vous
avez vu les sondages et a peint un élan
candidature de l'ancien taubira je
partage je partage complètement cela je
note quand même là aussi pour quelqu'un
dont la candidature n'est avéré que
depuis le 15 janvier elle s'est placée à
5% quasiment immédiatement 5 sur tous
les sondages et dans l'hérault ligne
parfois 3 est de moins en moins puisque
les derniers sont à 4 je vous dis pas
c'est la quintessence de la réussite et
qu'est ce que vous attendez est ce que
vous attendez en sursaut dans les
sondages au lendemain de cette primaire
et de quel ordre on attend simplement
aujourd'hui que les gens de gauche
continuent de dire très fort qu'ils ne
veulent pas en janvier l'élection
présidentielle celle que vous voyez dans
les sondages l'arrivée dans les sondages
de christiane taubira ça a pas du fait
augmenter le total gauche ça juste pour
distribuer
on est bien d'accord mais si tu essaies
de te lire avait imaginé qu'elle avait
un élan de gauche au mois de décembre
elle n'aurait pas proposé sa candidature
fin est quand même un peuple de gauche
que ton père doubt il faut quand même se
le dire une bonne fois pour toute à fait
ça fait des mois que ça dure et ça fait
même des années est ce que c'est ce qui
explique anne hidalgo et si loin
finalement dans les résultats de cette
prévient populaire moi je vais pas
commenter les résultats de chacun parce
que vous auriez pu et derrière anne
hidalgo on avisera sur pris la 5e place
dans les algues ont quand même hier soir
sa passion oui bien évidemment mais en
même temps j'allais dire c'est aussi
peut-être liée simplement aux
changements de pied régulier qu'elle a
pu avoir sur sur cette primaire et qui
ne sont pas facilitées je veux dire
aussi bien sûr que j'aurais pu
travailler que le parti socialiste est
une vieille tradition de fonctionnement
ensemble mais je pas en guerre contre le
parti socialiste
pas en guerre contre les verts on avait
d'ailleurs avec les verts discuter dès
le mois de décembre d'une façon
d'imaginer une coalition de gouvernement
donc il n'ya pas de ma part et de la
part du prg qui est cette vieille maison
politique parlons alors allez pas très
médiatique elle n'est pas très connue
elle est pas très puissante mais il ya
une forme de sagesse du fil de
l'histoire politique moi j'ai pour
habitude de ne pas considérer que mes
ennemis sont à gauche j'ai pour habitude
de considérer que dans les villes dans
les régions nous gouvernons ensemble et
que je ne comprends pas et que mon
problème c'est que t'es pas que moi qui
ne le comprennent pas les français ne
comprennent pas pourquoi dans une région
on est capable de gouverner ensemble et
pourquoi quand il s'agit de la france ça
ne serait plus possible c'est ça
fondamentalement qui créent aujourd'hui
le malaise à gauche et à droite jugeant
rezé à ma question qu'est ce qui se
passe et elle passe un coup chier
les gens disent non on veut pas on veut
pas s'allier avec toi c'est chacun son
couloir qu'est ce qui se passe à 100
christiane taubira ils veulent quoi
qu'il arrive est ce qu'il aura quoi
qu'il arrive en jeu c'est à nous de bien
être a déclaré une candidature à la
présidentielle avait soumis au vote de
la primaire le fait de valider et elle
était prête à se retirer ce qui n'est
quand même pas rien et le sait que ce
vote c'est un vote pour le rassemblement
de la gauche elle sait que c'est un vote
qui lui donne aussi une légitimité et
qui renvoie chacun à la responsabilité
individuelle et collective de leurs
partisans vous dit
les autres avancent que ces ateliers les
mercredis entendu comme tous les
candidats par la fondation abbé pierre
elles déroulent un plan média
je dis bah elle est plus je dis juste
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un devoir à gauche
de considérer que les bulletins ou le
bulletin qu'il y aura sur la table 10
avril est un qui emmène à l'ailé
je reviens à ma question est ce qu'il ya
des conditions pour qu'à l'heure
actuelle est ce que vous avez entendu
des conditions de la part de christiane
taubira hier soir je pourquoi est ce que
je vous ai justement c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pourquoi vous poser
cette question et ça tombe bien à l
avance on nous dit depuis le début
qu'elle n'ira pas au bout moi je ne sais
pas pourquoi je ne sais pas pourquoi on
le dit je dis qu'aujourd'hui elle dans
une
mais a partout où vous avez déjà une
légitimité citoyenne à partir du moment
où vous avancez dans une campagne à
partir moi ou vous continuez de
travailler rassemblement et je redis à
l'est sont quelques heures passées quand
même il y a les réactions immédiates il
vit à ce qui va se passer dans la
semaine laissons venir a aussi des
choses moi je ne suis pas il y aura
fabien roussel puisque fabien 11
il était pas d'en
appeler aux communistes et elle a dit
qu'elle appellerait fabien
ce matin vous êtes un homme heureux
d'avoir une candidate et qu'elle soit et
qu'elle incarne les valeurs du parti
radical je suis un homme préoccupé
je suis pas heureux quand je vois l'état
de la gauche aujourd'hui personne ne
peut l'être je sais bien je leur dis
n'est pas la candidate du parti radical
et center est une candidate qui peut
rassembler autour d'elle une gauche
multiples c'était quand même inespéré
pour vous d'avoir quelqu'un qui soit si
proche de vous non mais c'est ce qui est
assez important aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir peut-être et peut-être inespérée
le mot d'avoir peut-être une solution
pour rassembler la gauche et permet de
quelle paix dans cette élection
présidentielle c'est ça mon voeu le plus
cher et c'est ça le voeu des radicaux de
gauche
notre invité ce matin président du parti
radical de gauche
[Musique]